[Música]
cómo te levantas cada mañana
te levantas con objetivos y metas por
cumplir lo que harás ese día te acercará
más a tus sueños
o simplemente te levantas como parte de
una rutina
definitivamente una de las
características más fascinantes del ser
humano es la capacidad de proyectarse a
través del tiempo visualizando lo que
uno puede ser o lograr en otras palabras
la capacidad de soñar permítanme
compartirles mi experiencia
recuerdo claramente la escena en el
primer día del taller de robótica en mi
colegio todo el colegio estaba
emocionado los profesores los
estudiantes hablaban de lo que iba a
hacer este taller incluso si ustedes
veían la puerta de la sala de
computación donde se iba a ser el taller
podían ver una fila de unos 40 niños
emocionados ansiosos y llenos de euforia
esperando lo que iban a aprender de esta
clase los niños con mucha alegría y
mucho entusiasmo decían yo quiero
construir un bombo lvi para que nos
proteja y el otro te decía no yo quiero
construir un robot que me haga la tarea
incluso yo también les cuento que tenía
mis expectativas y deseos para esta
clase y yo les comento que quería
construir algo así
pero la verdad es que mi primer día
resulte construyendo algo con esto
y la verdad es que estas cosas pasan y
como les comenté eran muchos niños en el
taller de robótica y había pocos kits lo
que teníamos que hacer era hacer una
fila para construir robots y construir
el robot que tomaba entre 100 a 150
pasos dependiendo de qué modelo hacías y
lo que estábamos haciendo era que un
niño iba a construir el paso 1 al 10 el
otro del 10 del 20 y así se volvía un
ciclo entonces ahí imagínense ya
estábamos haciendo la fila para conocer
el robot yo estaba y ya me va a tocar ya
me va a tocar y mientras estaba haciendo
la fila me aseguraba de que sabía el
manual de construcción de que sabía leer
todas las piezas las instrucciones tenía
las piezas necesarias y ahora ya me va a
tocar ya me va a tocar veía a mi
compañero ya me va a tocar y en ese
momento en que me entregaban el robot
no había mejor sensación éramos solo yo
y el robot y cuando estaba construyendo
robots me aseguraba de poner bien la
rueda de ponerle su segurito de que las
piezas estaban bien conectadas los
cables en el lugar correcto y me
aseguraba de que entregaba mi mejor
trabajo a mi siguiente compañero y otra
vez estaba ahí lo que me toque otra vez
para armar el robots
y saben
aunque el tiempo efectivo de
construcción no era el más largo yo
realmente disfrutaba las clases de
robótica y para el tiempo en que
nuestros diseños fueran cada vez más y
más elaborados en las matemáticas
encontré un gran aliado la lógica y el
pensamiento matemático fueron claves
para que haga un gran un buen programa
en la computadora
y saben me parecía fascinante casi
mágico ver como unas instrucciones en el
software de tu computadora se convertían
en movimientos en el robot
estoy muy agradecida con el tiempo que
tuve en mi taller de robótica
y yo realmente amaba las clases
y saben a esta etapa de mi vida yo la
llamo pasión el despertar de la fuerza
[Aplausos]
y continuaron con las clases de robótica
y es cuando un día el profesor de
robótica llega y nos dice chicos les
cuento que hay una competencia
departamental para clasificar a esta
competencia departamental vamos a hacer
una competencia interna donde sólo los
tres mejores equipos van a representar
al colegio
yo les cuento que salí de esa charla con
el profesor muy esperanzada llena de
alegría y comenzaba a pensar
qué pasaría si lograra ganar
o si simplemente estoy entre uno de los
tres equipos que representan mi colegio
finalmente llegó el día de la
competencia todos estaban emocionados
alegres y con muchas esperanzas de ganar
entramos y decimos chicos nosotros la
tenemos la vamos a romper es nuestro día
sin embargo
los resultados fueron desastrosos
ni siquiera logré clasificar a la
competencia interna
y los sueños y esperanzas que comenzaban
a crecer a mi mente que comenzaba a
albergar fueron confrontados por la
realidad
y esta etapa de mi vida
yo la llamo
el imperio contraataca
[Aplausos]
y saben este pudo haber sido el final de
mi historia en el área de robótica
yo realmente me encontraba frustrada y
no lograba comprender por qué no sacaba
resultados positivos en algo que
verdaderamente me gustaba
si bien tenía esta manera de pensar
porque apenas tenía 12 años y no
comprendía el aspecto de muchas cosas de
la vida aunque de algo estaba segura mi
pasión por la matemática y la robótica
eran genuinas
pero no sabías cómo avanzar
en ese momento en ese tiempo el apoyo de
mis padres fue muy importante
ellos abrazaron la misma pasión que yo
tenía e incluso mi papá se convirtió en
mi entrenador de robótica
juntos hicimos el pacto de que ambos nos
íbamos a esforzar al 100% y dar lo mejor
de nosotros y yo creo que ambos fuimos
fieles de esa promesa yo me quedaba
hasta altas horas de la noche
investigando nuevos modelos de robots
nuevas maneras de construir uno y
mientras más me daba cuenta que quería
un robot más preciso y más perfecto en
sus movimientos necesitaba las
matemáticas
la precisión matemática era clave
y así fue que mientras mi amor y pasión
por la robot que estaba creciendo mi
amor por las matemáticas también se
profundizó
y es ahora que hoy en día yo cuento los
minutos restantes para tomar una clase
de matemáticas
de esa manera pasión y perseverancia
tomar hicieron una alianza y comenzaron
a dar frutos al principio logré
representar a mi colegio en una
competencia departamental tiempo después
mucho trabajo mucho esfuerzo un día dos
días de práctica no eran suficientes
teníamos que practicar toda la semana
unas cuatro horas al día y pan estábamos
representando a la paz en una
competencia nacional después practicamos
y ahora vamos a veces salíamos tan
decepcionados de los resultados pero no
nos rendimos nos esforzamos el doble el
triple nos sacrificamos más y tuve el
gran honor y el gran orgullo de
representar a bolivia en el mundial de
indonesia en yakarta
ese tiempo fue muy fue inolvidable y yo
lo atesoran mucho en mi corazón pero
también es que ahí aprendí muchas cosas
los paradigmas y maneras de pensar que
tenía cayeron
y a mi vuelta tenía una nueva mentalidad
aprendí que muchas limitaciones
simplemente están en nuestra cabeza
continué con la robótica y gracias a
dios representa a bolivia en múltiples
torneos internacionales primero como
competidora y tiempo después como
entrenador
sin embargo es ahí que mucha gente
no se da cuenta que el fracaso o la
derrota es lo más natural en el camino
hacia el éxito
incluso yo les confieso que aprendí
mucho más de mis derrotas que de las
victorias que tenía
en ese tiempo también aprendí a amarme
tal como soy potenciaron las habilidades
y desechar algunas actitudes negativas
que tenía
si bien era una niña tímida e
introvertida con con temores logré
emigrar de un carácter tímido aún no
determinado
hoy en día puedo decir que soy
introvertida pero tímida ya no soy
y cada vez
y empezaba un nuevo proyecto o me
levantaba de una derrota comencé a
sentir de que pasión y perseverancia no
me servirían para continuar
al principio pensé que esto simplemente
era la adolescencia y se me iba a pasar
pero esta idea continuaba en mi cabeza
por mucho tiempo
y es así que en el último viaje que
realice en agosto de 2017 encontré algo
que va más allá de la pasión y la
perseverancia y esta etapa de mi vida yo
la llamo una nueva esperanza
[Aplausos]
y dónde fue que encontré esta esperanza
bueno pues la encontré en houston texas
en el campamento united space school de
la nasa donde reúnen a más de 50 jóvenes
de alrededor del mundo para potenciar
sus habilidades en ingeniería
aeroespacial mecánica y ciencias en este
campamento lo primero que había era una
semana exhaustiva de exámenes donde
obviamente veían tu aptitud académica
como resolvía sus problemas como
trabajabas en equipo y tu personalidad
en esta semana de exámenes surgió el
rumor de que entrara el equipo rojo era
muy difícil porque el equipo rojo se
encargaba de construir la nave de
diseñarla y de calcular las órbitas de
transmisión
llegó el día en que iban a dar los
resultados de quienes entraban al equipo
era un ambiente tenso y podías sentir el
suspenso
y anunciaron que dos latinos habían
entrado al equipo rojo
isabel a grecia ni de la argentina
y para sorpresa de muchos una boliviana
su servidora priscila ontiveros
[Aplausos]
allá en la nasa puede trabajar de codo a
codo con astronautas calcular órbitas de
trayectoria con los científicos más
calificados de todo el mundo pero
también tuve mi momento de hacer los
problemas de matemática más locos con
otros chicos que también les apasionaba
la ciencia
y es ahí que me puse a pensar
cómo es que llegué acá
cómo es que aquella niña tímida que
alguna vez le daba miedo a levantar la
mano en el colegio es que llegó hasta la
nasa
y es ahí donde me di cuenta de algo que
de la misma manera que en la física un
vector tiene un valor dirección y
sentido
la pasión y la perseverancia necesitan
desde una dirección y un sentido
necesitan de un propósito
y precisamente cuando nosotros
encontremos nuestro propósito podremos
perseverar en lo que nos apasiona en en
cuyo proceso hagamos de esto un estilo
de vida en cual crezcamos como personas
pero también hagamos felices a otros
ustedes
ahora
están haciendo lo que les apasiona
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]